[Music]
so
today i am excited to talk about the
third edition
of testdeck so i'm going to start
by talking a little bit about like what
do i mean by that you
certainly don't know what a version of a
package is but what do i mean by this
being the third edition
of test that i'm going to talk through
kind of
three big new features in this in this
version in this edition
uh see how we test that now displays
differences much more clearly using the
waldo package
we'll talk about a new type of testing
new type of testing to test that called
snapshot tests
very briefly talk about testing in
parallel or multi-process testing
and then finally i'm going to give you a
real quick goody bag of a bunch of
little small stuff that will hopefully
make your life a little bit easier when
using test that
so the the big news with this release of
test at least the upcoming
release test that 3.0 is we're going to
introduce the idea of this
third edition and i should say any
anything you're going to hear about
today
is also explained in more detail than
vignettes
on the test that website so if you want
to learn more about anything i say today
feel free to take a look at those
vignettes and if they don't explain
they they don't help you understand
what's going on please file an issue so
we can make them better
so the basic idea of the addition is
that we want to make breaking changes to
test that test that's
like 10 years old or something and
you know there's a there's a bunch of
things in the package that we now regret
but uh tess that's kind of a victim of
its own popularity there's
you know something like four or five
thousand packages on crayon that
use test that and many of them are not
actively developed so there's no way we
can change test that
without breaking a bunch of packages and
many of these packages since they
wouldn't be maintained there's no one
people would they'll just end up off
crown because people wouldn't have that
energy to
to um fix them so the idea of an
addition is that this is something you
have to deliberately opt into so if you
want to use
many of the new features or all of the
new features of tests that i talk about
today
you have to deliberately choose to use
the third edition of test that
and just so to do that you basically
have to add a line in a description file
config slash test that slash edition so
if you don't do this you'll continue to
use this the second edition that's the
existing behavior of test that
if you do this you'll get if you do
change this you'll get a bunch of
new features and a bunch of things which
i'll explain shortly which
which have gone away so the kind of idea
is that um it should take hopefully
you know less than 30 minutes to convert
a package to use the third edition
you know it's a little bit of work
hopefully not too much work
but it just generally gets you up to
date with all of our best
current best practices and i should say
if this kind of idea of this edition
idea is successful
it's something we're likely to try out
in other packages a way of allowing
existing code to continue working while
giving you
the choice to opt in to a new set of
behaviors
so additions will always be coupled with
a major version
so that means test that two and
everything else
before this counts as the second edition
test that 3.0
can use the second edition that's the
default behavior or you can opt into
using the third edition
and if one day you know many probably
multiple years down the line we decided
to introduce a fourth edition
then that would be tied to test at 4.5
so what's going away in the third
edition um these are the things that are
most likely to lead you to change your
tests
while the context function is going away
we've kind of been moving away from this
for quite some time in favor of
just using the name of the test file
there's no need to kind of duplicate the
information in the test file in another
function which you have to remember to
update if you ever move your test files
we've also been lately in devtools and
use this
building kind of a stronger coupling
between
files in the r directory and files in
the test directory so that there's a
there's a kind of a one-to-one
correspondence
which gives you a bunch of handy
keyboard shortcuts and development tools
ah the very old expect that function is
going away this was
the kind of first api uh the first
excessively
clever api that tests that used with
every test
kind of had the flavor you could read it
like a sentence like test that blah
is true and i pretty quickly discovered
decided that that was um
excessively clever not very good and so
we we're finally
deprecating that for good expect is um
we're deprecating in favor of expect
s3 class expect s4 class and expect typo
just to be more precise about what
exactly you're trying to express
uh expect equivalent i'll talk about a
little bit later but we're basically
that's just giving argument to expect
equal or expect identical
uh some of the the mocking functions
going away
in favor of more feature for packages
and then finally we
are moving away from setup and teardown
in favor of uh test fixtures
which i'm not going to talk about today
but there's a whole vignette about
them if you want to learn more and
hopefully that's kind of all i need to
say just these are the functions that
are going away
uh like if you really really believe any
of these functions are important like
now is the time to speak up and say you
want to keep these
otherwise when you switch the second
switch to the third edition rerun your
tests
you'll get deprecation messages telling
you what to replace these functions with
so that's kind of the stuff that's going
away now i want to focus
on the cool new features and i think the
feature you are most likely to encounter
and the most likely to give you pleasure
in your life is that comparisons with
expect
equal and expect identical or test
failures with expected error
equal and expect identical and now much
easier
to understand so previously expect equal
uses the base
all dot equal function this was never
really what all that equal was intended
for but it
kind of did an okay job but there's a
few cases where
it just doesn't give very useful output
and so here i'm comparing
empty cars without the first column
to empty cars the full data set
and you'll notice i get a lot of output
well it tells me that there's 10 string
messages in the names it doesn't really
help me
it tells me there's a length mismatch
and then it gives me a bunch of mean
relative differences
so this certainly tells me that there's
a difference but it doesn't kind of
concisely
crisply point me to the fact there's a
column missing in this data frame
so now we use wall though
so to use this i'm just going to use
this function called local addition this
is not something you generally need to
use
in your tests because you'll convert a
whole package
to use a third edition but we provide
this local addition function
for you know writing stuff like this for
writing venues so you can explain it
explain about this new edition this just
temporarily
sets the addition to the third edition
so now
um use the third edition and now this is
the new waldo output so the kind of the
first principle
is that waldo is going to give you the
most important
differences first and in this case i
think the most important difference is
that the lengths are different
and then it tells us what the names are
how the names have changed
lining up the old names
lining up so the the actual names with
the expected names
and then it uses color to highlight the
fact that in the expected
there's another column called mpg and
then finally down here we get exact
description that well the names are
different but the value is also
different
uh the actual it's
absent and as i read this that is
clearly
not the case because it's absent from
the expected so i think i've
i've messed up the labels here so i'll
have to fix these i should say
uh expected mpg is absent and this
should say actual mpg
is a double vector so that just
allows you once they fix those labels to
precisely see what the differences
are so here we've switched to use the
third edition
waldo then shows the most differences
important differences first it uses
color to help height and it uses color
to help highlight differences
oh and it always uses the names of
things where possible just because that
makes it easier to understand
exactly where the differences lie
so another little example here i have a
factor
uh versus an ordered factor with
uh one extra level when you look at the
expect
equal output from the second edition
you'll see like it kind of tells you
that they're different but it's hard
because it doesn't include the values
to know exactly what's changed when we
switch to the third edition now we can
see well there's a new element of the
class vector it's ordered
and there's a new element of the levels
which is d
and hopefully this will make it much
much easier to see
exactly what's gone wrong and certainly
in my own this is like this is the
number one reason i've been converting
packages to use the third edition of
test that
just because it makes things so much
easier to see
when something's gone wrong so if you
want to learn more about waldo you can
go to the waldo website
which shows a bunch of kind of examples
shows some of
the principles uh a lot of the
differences of the values are powered by
this really nice
uh package called diff opt uh by brody
graslam which
uses the same algorithm as the diff
utility on linux which just makes it
really easy to kind of narrow in exactly
what has changed between two vectors
this change also makes it now possibly
precise
about what's the difference between
expect equal expect identical and expect
equivalent
which are always a little vague in the
past now all of these functions are
equivalents to expect
identical but with some extra argument
set
so if you use expect equal that's
equivalent to expect identical
except that it ignores small floating
point differences
or if you use expect equivalent which is
now deprecated
it's just the same as using expect equal
or expect equivalent with
ignore attribute equals true that's the
only thing that expect equivalent does
is it just ignores attributes
now we're going to make that precise and
a function argument and then any other
arguments
and expect identical expect equal passed
on to waldo compare
which gives you the ability to kind of
fine-tune your comparisons
uh as needed now this is such a great
idea you might wonder well why can't i
just why can't i work for the second
edition as well
well unfortunately when i implemented
expect equal
it turns out that i made uh
made a rather silly mistake when
implementing the tolerance
uh comparison so depending on exactly
which code path that goes down it
computes the
tolerance in slightly different ways one
way it always uses the
absolute tolerance in one way it uses
absolute relative tolerance so there's
basically no way
i did a few experiments there's no way
regardless of which one i pick it causes
like hundreds of cran packages to break
so that that's the main reason that this
has to be
in the third edition uh but there's a
few other small things particularly if
you're testing code in a modeling
package
uh all dot equal which used to power
expect equal ignores environments of
formulas and models
uh sorry formulas and uh functions
uh waldo does not but it provides a
couple of arguments
to um allow you to override that if you
need to
and there's just a few other small
things around like posix ct
so i think the behavior of waldo is
generally better it's a little bit
stricter and when it fails it'll give
you clearer results
but we can't just turn it on for
everyone because it will break a bunch
of tests
so you're going to have to deliberately
opt into it
okay so that's waldo i think that's like
kind of number one
feature uh like again
i have found it like so useful in
debugging tests myself
to have that much much much clearer
display
the next big feature i want to talk
about is snapshot testing
again this comes with a vignette so if
you want to learn more about it you can
read the vignette
if the vignette doesn't make sense
please file an issue so we can make it
better
but the basic idea is this is a
slight this is a new type of testing so
normally in unit tests
you describe the expected output using
code and in the vast majority of cases
this is a really really good idea
because it allows you to kind of
describe what you expect
and in some sense the tests help
document
you know because it tests the code
encoders
means of communication they kind of help
describe the expected behavior of the
functions as well
but sometimes describing the expected
output is just like really annoying like
if it contains a bunch of special
characters like
quotes or backslashes you have to spend
a bunch of time like carefully escaping
them
and then when something goes wrong it's
hard to see exactly like
you've got to unescape them in your head
it's just a pain or maybe it's very
large like maybe you want to check an
entire html page or multiple paragraphs
of text
as you expect or maybe it's it's not
even something that you can easily
describe with text
it's an image or something else so the
idea of a snapshot or golden test which
uh
idea used in other programming languages
and other testing
packages um
and and uh test that inspiration draws
primarily from
jest which is a javascript testing
package that uh
joe cheng uh shared his experiences with
me a bunch and
persuaded me that this was something
really useful
but so the snapshot test the a key idea
is that instead of recording the results
inline and the test itself they'll store
it in a separate file
and test that provides a bunch of tools
for
um looking after that from managing
their files so i will create it
automatically the first time you run it
and then it gives you tools to update it
when you decide there really has been a
change
and if you've used verify output or
expect known output which we've never
really advertised because we've never
really been particularly happy with them
uh the snapshot tests basically
supersede those functions
so what does a snapshot snapshot test
looks like
look like so here i'm just going to give
you a quick simulation
in the presentation and i'll show you
what this looks like in a real package
so here i've got two files foo dot r
i've just got this very silly
and simple function which has a mistake
in it
you can see which will affect shortly
and then i've got a test
so i run fo i expect it as a character
vector
and then i'm going to use this new
expectation expect snapshot output and
this doesn't have
like what the expected value is because
it's going to save it to disk
so the first time i run this it's going
to say warning create snapshot reference
and it creates a new file and i forgot
to put the
correct directory in here inside
the inside the test that directory is
going to create a new directory called
snaps underscore snaps
and inside that it's going to have a
file called food.md
right so our r file is called food r our
test file is called test
foo dot r and then our snapshot for that
the snapshot file is going to be called
food.md
so all of these are just names have a
strong naming convention so you can
easily
find which snapshot corresponds to which
test which corresponds to which r file
so what does that snapshot contain well
it's a markdown file
i'll kind of explain the syntax shortly
but we use a heading
to indicate that this is the test and
then it's going to
put the output of that test
directly in that file so now if i run it
again
i run that test again the test is going
to work because nothing's changed and so
the test
the test will pass if i change it to fix
that typo
i run the test again i'm getting an
error
saying that the previous value was
something conflicted
and the new value of something
complicated
now the downside of snapshot tests is
that there's no way to know
like what is correct so you as a human
now have to step in and intervene so if
this is correct if you really did
need to make mean to make this change
you can run snapshot accept
and that will accept the change
and the way that this works is that when
you have this value when something is
changed
there will be a new up there will be a
new markdown file
which contains the new value if you
accept it
then it will replace that with the old
value
okay so let's that's kind of the big
picture um
so let's just dive into that for a
slightly more realistic example start
with a simple one so i have this package
i have the same test which i copied
before and i'm going to run this test
and i'm going to run this test by
pressing command t
which is a shortcut for dev tools
test file so this keyboard shortcut
takes advantage of that convention that
if you've got a file called food.r
the corresponding test will be
testosterone
and so this says we've added a new
snapshot
this is the value of that snapshot i can
look at it here's this
markdown file again which i'll explain
shortly and then if i run that test
again
oops if i run that test again
you'll see that all the tests have
passed
the other thing if you've used devtools
test file before which i'll talk about
briefly later
is there's now a slightly different
display a slightly more compact display
to hopefully make it easier to
run tests for a single file
interactively
so i change this i'm going to correct
that typo
i'm going to test again and now the test
fails
because a snapshot has changed so it
shows you the current value
which is something complicated and it
shows you the previous value which is
something complected
now if this wasn't if this is a
deliberate change you can run
snapshot accept if this wasn't a
deliberate change oh that was just a
typo
i can fix it and rerun it all my tests
pass again
so if you've ever used verify output
this is a little bit different because
verify output will automatically update
the kind of true known value on on disk
which
forced you to use it with get basically
so i'm going to fix this
the test fails you can see now in my
snaps directory i've got
foo that's the food.md that's the
previous value
and i've got food.new.md which is the
new value
so i look at this i decide that is
actually correct and then i can just
copy and paste this
and now
food.md has the correct
result and i can test that test that
again
okay so let's look at a slightly more
complicated example so this
is a bullets function
and it's basically used to create
html bullets
so it looks like this and this is
like a little annoying to test because
if you're going to put this in a test
you'd have to escape all of these new
lines and kind of carefully
manage all the white spaces just it's
just a pain so to test this code
it's a little easier to use a snapshot
test
so i can run this test
and now here is a test snapshot file
with multiple expectations in it
the first one i am just using a bullet
with a single
um a single bullet and a six second also
the single bullet it also saves the id
so if i later want to change this
bullets function maybe i've decided
actually i don't want this
indent let's get rid of that
and rerun the test again the changes use
wall though to highlight what's changed
so it's a little bit hard to see this
but this is the thing that's the same
it's in gray
what's changed well we can see there is
now
now no space where there was before
so look at this i decide yep that's a
deliberate change
and then i run snapchat exit bullets
collets to update that snapshot
and that basically is snapshot testing
um of course there's more documentation
i think it'll take a little while
to get your hit around it all i've shown
you expect snapshot output here
there's also expect snapshot which is
well as printed out but also captures
messages warnings errors
uh there's also expect snapshot error if
you want to capture specifically
just error messages and then we've got
expect snapshot value which captures
return value so this is
a little bit different this is um if you
for example wanted to test
the output from like a complicated
function you just want to make sure it
doesn't change without warning you can
use exp
snapshot value
and then again of course there's the
vignette which you can look at
well i guess i i can't show because i
didn't i've installed the development
version of the package which doesn't
have the videos but
you can go to the website actually let's
just let's just go to the website
and then we can see all these vignettes
here's one on snapshot testing
um just giving you a little bit more
detail
about what i just talked about
so the only other thing to mention is
just what are these what are these files
look like why are they markdown files
well if you're writing this this package
is a collaborative project and using
github or
some other tool where you do code review
it's really important that these
snapshots be human readable
because when someone goes to review your
code they need to look at the snapshot
and say
is this a reasonable change or not so
they use markdown
uh the each file again is there's one
snapshot file per test file
which normally corresponds to a file in
our directory
there's a heading for the test name and
then if you have multiple snapshot
expectations and a single test are
separated by the horizontal role of
three dashes
one thing that i'm working on at the
moment and
with some help from joshua const is
a shiny app that will help you review
all of these differences
and accept them or reject them with by
clicking buttons rather than typing some
of the console
and the other big part of that is
providing tools for doing
image snapshots as well so this is
something that we've
implemented in two places and shiny test
which is used for testing shiny and v
differ which is used for testing gg pod
two the
idea is you're going to pull out the
common code centralize and test that and
invest a bunch in this whole
snapshotting idea
so you've got a really nice workflow if
you do need to do
image tests image tests are complicated
because they can change for all sorts of
reasons
unrelated to your code um but sometimes
they're all you have
and they are a really important part of
testing both shiny itself and ggpot 2
itself
okay so that's snapshot tests main idea
of snapshot tests
is that compared to regular unit tests
which have the expected results
in the test file snapshot tests or the
expected results
in another file which makes them
suitable
for testing large output output with
quote marks and backslashes in it and
for testing things that you simply
cannot describe with text
like images
next i wanted to talk briefly about
parallel tests
uh this is still work in progress uh by
gabor
chadi and again you're gonna have to
activate this specifically for your
package
again by putting another line uh in your
description
config test that parallel true but the
payoff for this is pretty big
it's going to run your tests on multiple
processes
so if you have uh long-running tests
this is going to make a big improvement
to the total running time of your tests
now the the downside is like there's a
little bit of overhead associated with
that starting up multiple
r packages uh multiple r processors
loading all the
code in those um so there's a little bit
of overhead so if your tests are very
fast like if your tests all run in under
a second it's probably not gonna have a
huge
impact but if you've got tests that you
know take five or ten seconds the whole
test suite takes minutes
then this should hopefully have a really
big positive impact on your workflow
there are some downsides um
as well as this big upside of speed
tests will now kind of effectively run
in stochastic order because
there you'll have like four processes
and each process
takes kind of the next test in the queue
and so depending on exactly how long
each test takes to run
like they the tests might get run in
different a different order
and this basically means if you have any
dependency between your tests
which is relatively easy to introduce
because normally they'll run in
alphabetical order um
if there is any dependency between your
test files you'll get like
random test failures that occur
sometimes but don't occur
other times depending on exactly which
order the tests are running
in other words this is like a dependency
debugging
nightmare um so we're still thinking
about tools to kind of
ensure that if that happens to you we've
got some mode
debugging mode you can switch on to get
more insight
and then also if you've used like global
setup or tear down for example
like you set up a database or some csv
file for all of your tests you're gonna
need to think that through in a little
bit more detail
because those setup and teardown files
are now
run by multiple processors so there's
going to be a little bit of work
to convert your tests to use parallel
we're still
working on this you know there's a
vignette if you want to learn more i
want to try it out
but we're hopeful that this will make a
big impact if you've got long running
tests
so i've talked about this idea of the
third edition this is a
special mode you'll have to switch on if
you want to use all the latest and
greatest test that features
uh we've talked about waldo which makes
comparisons or tests
makes the test failures from expect
equal and friends much much easier
we talked about snapchatting tests we
talked about running tests in parallel
now i just want to show you kind of a
bunch of little features that i think
are kind of cool
um so in the course of working on test
that for this release
made a bunch of improvements to the
reporters the reporters are the things
that actually go and
like generate the results so when i
press
test this is this is done by a reporter
if i press command shift t
to run all of the tests these are
different reporters
one reporter that you'd never normally
use is called stop
you don't normally call it explicitly
but it's called stop reporter
that what that's what happens um
that's the test that's run so that's the
reporter that's run
when you run a test interactively so
here i'm just running a test
uh which is not working for probably
reasons that i need to look into
but if i create a actually i have
another example
over here if i run this test this is the
stop reporter
now it clearly tells you that your test
passed
um and gives you some emoji
uh if your test does not pass
it nicely displays the failures
and it also displays any warnings and
really conveniently it also displays the
back trace
for the warning so if you've got
warnings in any of your tests now
they get a full back trace so you can
figure out exactly where that warning
came from
um one of my kind of pet peeves is
um let me do this
is this i have
i have partial matching warnings turned
on and if this
occurs like somewhere deep inside a
function so the functions another
function is really hard to track down
now in your test you get this nice back
trace so you can figure out exactly
what function what sequence of functions
leads to that problem
okay so that's the stop reporter which
is used in debugging so it now uses
color uses
emoji and generally gives you more
information about
problems when you're interactively
running tests i showed you earlier that
compact progress reporter
that is the single
that is the single line here which gives
you kind of a running this is a little
bit lower
a little bit fast we could do a slow
test
so just doing a little loop here which
is going to do an expectation
and then sleep for a little bit so you
can see it like counts up
a little slower
so you get like a running um
a running progress bar in some sense of
all the tests that are running so you
know exactly what's going on
uh i've made the regular reporter which
uh you see most often when you're
running all the tests in your package
the biggest thing is um i have added a
bunch of new
new praise um
that uses small emoji i
um these random praise
kind of beer into a little bit into
their joke territory but uh hopefully
they're just something a fun little
feature of test that that
keeps you motivated and keeps you going
when your tests are working well
finally the last reporter is the check
reporter that's run inside of our
command
check now reports all of the problems so
it also reports warnings and skips tests
it tells you all of your skips tests by
type which is really useful for checking
that you haven't accidentally skipped
tests that you meant to run and it also
creates an
rds file with a machine readable um list
of all of the tests
that's probably not something you're
going to use directly but it is
something that we all start to build
into our tooling so that
things like uh getup actions can give
you nicer
displays of your tests and so on
we've also made a few changes to the way
that the condition
functions work so here i have a function
that calls warn and message
and now if a condition
like a message a warning or an error is
not explicitly caught by your
expectation it will continue to bubble
up
so if i run this line
and i spell this correctly if i run this
line
this expectation passes it does find a
warning called hi
but the message called buy still bubbles
up
or if i say i expect a message called by
i'll see a warning called hi so if i
want to capture both of them
i need to use expect message and expect
warning together
this hopefully will give you better
control over exactly
what's going on it's going to cause a
few more warnings in your tests
uh these won't cause your package to
fail our commands check
but they will require a little bit of
work to make sure that those tests
are as you expect if you
want to get just ignore them you can
still rather than using expectations you
can just switch to the base functions
suppress
messages and suppress warnings if you
don't care about them
now you might notice here that we've got
expectations nested inside of
expectations and you might kind of
naturally think well
why can't i use the pipe for that
unfortunately you cannot
currently do that because the pipe
eagerly evaluates
everything so if i do this you get
a buy and a high and then this fails
because
this is called before this is called
we will start to announce a new work in
magruder that will make this work
and hopefully make magruder a little
more compatible with
uh the native pipe that is unlikely to
appear in the next
version of r as well
okay so that and that also means if you
one of the
i don't know 10 people in the world who
use the all arguments so expect warning
expect message
that's now deprecated you have to take a
slightly different approach but
i'm pretty confident that's going to be
a it's a much nicer api overall
and should not change any existing
shouldn't change existing behavior too
much
and the last thing is if you've ever
used expect error and it gives you this
message
to set the class uh we no longer
encourages you to do that it kind of
fixed one type of test fragility
basically the cost of increasing
just introducing a different type of
agility and so now you're better off
just using expect snapchat error if you
want to check that a specific
error occurs because that just gives you
a bunch of nice features for managing
the change over time
okay so just about to wrap up which is
great so there's plenty of time for
questions
uh so what have i talked about today
first uh
test that 3.0 is coming out soon i
should say we probably start the release
process in about a month
which means it's at least two months
before it's on cran
uh so i it would really be great if you
would try it out and
this is the right time to let us know if
this is
causing you pain so we can fix it before
release
uh plenty of time to do that uh so the
third edition
is going to be part of test that 3.0
which will be on cran
and at least well as soon as possible
it's probably two months it's likely to
be a little longer than that
the third edition you will have to
deliberately opt into
that gives you a bunch of new features
at the cost of doing a little bit of
work to clean up
old apis the new edition uses waldo
to make comparisons which will hopefully
make the test failures much easier to
debug
it provides snapshot tests which are an
alternative form of testing where the
expected results are stored on separate
files
rather than inline and code and then
the test that provides some functions to
help manage those files
so that you can accept changes when you
have made them deliberately
or revert changes when you've made them
accidentally
test that 3.0 will also introduce
parallel testing
um which again will be a little bit of
setup work just to make sure your global
setup and teardown works appropriately
and you haven't don't accidentally have
in the dependencies between your tests
but the payoff will be if you have slow
tests they should run much much faster
because i run in parallel
and then finally i showed you a bunch of
goodies many of them featuring a
emoji that will hopefully make your
day-to-day life easy test out a little
bit more fun a little bit more
so if you do want to try it out today
you need to get the development version
of test that
and the development version of devtools
and then in your
in your package if this is a package on
uh
that uses continuous integration or
similarly you'll need to add
test that to remotes and you'll need to
accept the addition to the third edition
to take advantage of all the latest and
greatest features
so there was a lot of content in 40
minutes again
hopefully if you didn't take in
everything i was saying
there's plenty of additional material
and all of the vignettes
and if you don't find those
understandable please let me know so we
can
make them better thank you and now
hopefully jenny will have some questions
for me yeah
so the first big one is i think people
want to hear more
about why you're doing a third
edition so why not create an entirely
new package
the same way that ply r led to d ply r
or why not create test that three
or why can you not do this through
semantic versioning of the existing
package
okay so let's the first question is like
why why not a new package
and that was something i considered but
like 90 of the code between the second
and edition and the third edition are
the same
like the biggest difference with the
third edition is it just takes stuff
away from you stuff that we now
regret so if we created a new package
we'd have two packages that have like 90
overlap in the code
and whenever there was a bug we'd have
to remember to fix it in in both
packages
so i think for this case we're like most
of the stuff is the same we're just
trying to get rid of
um some new things
uh i i think creating a new package
would be would be overkill
um the question about semantic
versioning is something that
like tests that does use semantic
versioning this is a major version will
be tested 3.0
but that actually that doesn't really
help um in the r community because
you only have a single version of a
package installed on your computer
and in a library you can kind of work
around that but it's a little
fiddly and for packages on crayon they
always use the latest version of the
packaging crayon
so if i just released test that 3.0
with all of these new features in it
like something like 500 packages would
break on cran because they would
automatically use
the version of test that on crown so i
think that that's why
those are like we we want to make a
little bit of friction
so that you have to deliberately choose
to use this new testing
use these new conventions you just
basically stop using old stuff
that you should have stopped using a
while ago
without duplicating a bunch of code that
we didn't have to maintain
in two places okay
so now i have a series of questions and
the list is growing longer
that are smaller and we'll just work
through as many as we can
so this first one is have you tested
whether
snapshotting plays nice with
things like cover or the good practice
package
does this third edition work have any
effect
on shiny test so kind of talking about
how this
works with other packages yeah so cover
i mean snapshot testing is just testing
it just works
exactly the way you'd expect with cover
uh i don't know
that much about good practice i would i
would think it would not been to say
i don't think it would cause problems
for for good practice
um shiny test it's not
clear precisely how this will play out
um i've been having kind of bigger
discussions with the shiny team
about how testing shiny should work
um because my vision for testing shiny
is
quite different from their vision of
testing shiny apps and so we're just
working
towards that i i think in an ideal world
eventually
shiny test would use kind of more of
this new this new snapshotting
infrastructure
that um test that provides but there's
some other big changes that have to
happen to shiny tears so i
you know it's hard to say today whether
that shiny test will eventually kind of
integrate this better
or um there will be a new package that's
kind of a success of the shiny test
um they used you know uses some other
stuff and there's more focus on snapshot
testing but i test that
if you want to kind of see my take on um
testing shiny i'm working on this
chapter at the moment
if you follow the shiny test repo you'll
notice that i've recently
recently triaged like a hundred and
something issues so i'm like thinking
about this a lot i'm starting to work on
it
uh thinking about the test i don't
exactly know what the answer is but
um you can kind of see my latest
thinking in this package
and this and this chapter of mastering
shiny which will get updated
you know pretty pretty rapidly in the
next week or two
all right the next one is do test
snapshots need to be
included in the package or could you
exclude them if they're large and then
developers can recreate them from a
stable version
i think if you want people to be able to
run your tests you have to include them
in your package
um because they are literally like the
correct
out the correct output um one thing i
did forget to
mention is that snapshot tests are not
right will be skipped on cran
automatically you can opt out of that
with an argument if you want
just because if if a snapshot test fails
it isn't necessarily
true that it's like a real meaningful
failure it might be an incidental
difference or a difference from a
downstream package but you don't want to
cause
a failure on cran but yes if you want
people to run your test you have to
include the correct
you have to include the expected results
in the package
all right is it possible to use snapshot
tests if the function
does not return anything but rather has
a side effect
so i mentioned briefly
expect snapshot which captures the side
effects of messages warnings and errors
uh if it's making other changes to the
global state
you would need to make that kind of
explicit you know like if it's attaching
if your function attaches a package you
know you might do expect snapshots
uh like search
which would capture the the search path
or maybe if it's creating
files in the directory you could use um
so it doesn't um directly handle side
effects apart from messages warnings and
errors
but you could easily wrap up you know a
little function
that captures those side effects it
makes them explicit and snapshot that
all right the next person missed a
little bit about what's going on with
context but
but sees that it's deprecated and
thinks that it's needed when the j unit
reporter
so how is how are those two things going
to work out
uh i don't so let me just find
a let me see if i can quickly find a
package
just so i can explain the context for
this change to context a lot more
okay so this is just the per package i
just searched to find all the uses of
context
and you can see like the test lmap.r
file contains a called a context lmap
see test s-mapper.r
called as it contains a called a context
as
underscore mapper which is a little
mildly inconsistent
or test when contains are called the
context when
tests that you tools contains are called
the contextual so
by and large is like a one-to-one
mapping between what you put in the
context and the name of the file
and that is just um like
you know you don't want that duplication
because you end up with inconsistencies
or maybe if i can find oh here we
can see that this this is a test for
pmap it probably used to be test
pmap but we renamed the file and forgot
to update the test
context and so now there's like this
mismatch between the two
so that's the reason why we're getting
rid of context because it's just
it just introduces this duplication from
little real games
but the context is still kind of
implicit like we just take
the file name so the context that tests
that the junit reporter for example will
use
would just be map underscore n so it
shouldn't change anything
practically with the junit reporter
okay so this is a person like me who
uses with mock and local mock so if
they're going to be deprecated what is
the suggested way to mock
functions in external packages i read
that the goal of mocker the package
mocker
is to provide a drop-in replacement but
it does not have this feature
so basically um the way that
with mark works um
is truly
an abuse of r um
and it does something that i now believe
to be tremendously ill-advised
and the chances of it stopping working
in a future version of r
are high because what it does is so
uh bizarre and horrific um
[Music]
so basically you have to use and you
have to use another approach so both
um the maca and mockery packages provide
slightly different techniques
unfortunately you just have to
you have to use those um although i'm
just
so concerned
that the way that with mark works is is
not
it's not good and it's surprising that
it hasn't caused any problems to date
so i just yeah unfortunately it's like
something that
is really nice and really useful but was
achieved in a really
really horrible way um does snapshot
have a limit on the size
of the data and can you combine snapshot
tests with more explicit tests of the
snapshot
uh yeah so that was kind of so there's
no limit on the size
um and i think you know generally you
know you'll
you'll you'll sort of mingle
snapchat testing with regular testing
like where you can like if this is a
list
you might want to test that this is a
specific value and there's another
component of the
list that's just a you know a big blob
that you
don't want to kind of type out so i
would imagine you know i really imagine
that you will want to mingle those as
much as possible
um i think it will be tempting um
to overuse snapshot testing just because
it's so convenient because you have to
write like the right hand side of expect
equal you have to you know to make clear
and you hear exactly what you're
expecting
uh but i think if you do that if you if
you use snapchatting too much you'll
find your
tests are a little bit fragile and kind
of break more often than you otherwise
like and that will kind of push you
naturally back towards a finer grained
unit testing that you're that you're
used to and test that
you know of course putting really large
files into your package is going to be
annoying for other reasons
um so i don't think you want to put like
you know megabytes of data using this
but certainly like kilobytes of data
which would be a pain to put in a test
file it's a really
nice sweet spot for snapchat testing
okay i have two questions that are a
little bit of emoji
pushback not to be a killjoy but praise
seems unnecessary why not
include it as a suggested package and
then also is there a way to suppress
emojis or build pipelines that
may not support them uh so some people
really
i don't know so first of all it doesn't
use the praise package
it just uses its own well i guess it
does
is that right let me refresh my memory
i guess it does use the praise package
which is a tiny package so
i guess we could make this a suggested
package but it just seems like
i don't know if someone did a pull
request that made praise into a
suggested package rather than a
dependent package i'd consider it but it
just doesn't
i don't think it practically really
reduces the cost of installing test that
in any practical way
uh if you don't want emojis you can just
turn or you can't turn the emojis off
although they will be automatically
turned off
if you're not in a uta 8 locale which is
normally on
windows but you can
test report
i remember what's it called progress
reporter if you really don't like them
you can turn them off by um
calling setting stuff up in a special
way and saying show praise equals
false but the praise only shows up
in reporters that are used interactively
it never shows up
in um in reporters that are used
in our command check or in other
continuous integration contexts so i
think it's
like it's to me it's purely it's just a
fun thing
um i don't think there's anything wrong
with introducing a little
a little fun and joy into unit testing
and
you know by and large people really like
it but if you don't you can turn it off
okay i've been using a waldo a bit is
there any planned way to control
the amount of output that is shown
um
yes um
[Music]
so someone actually just did a pull
request
to waldo so that you can choose to print
any number of changes
uh by default waldo doesn't show it
shows like 10
changes with the kind of assumption that
if
you have more than 10 changes you
probably want to start
by fixing the first team changes and
that will reveal more
more issues um i think this is something
i
this is just purely um driven by
pragmatics you don't want failures that
generate
hundreds of lines of output when the
wind is like something horrifically
wrong
in the first line they eat that is
actionable um so
i i i don't have a good sense of what
like we have where that schleider should
be set by default and how you should
slide it to more or less output
um yet but you know that's something
that we'll keep thinking about and
iterating on as we
as we work on this and in reality
in our packages all right i've picked
two last questions one is super tiny and
then one's a little bit bigger and makes
a good conclusion
so the tiny off-topic question is how do
you get the get
branch into your prompt in the r console
oh yeah so if you're wondering what this
this thing was this is the
the name of my active git branch and
that is
some code in my r profile that uses
uh gabor's prompt package to just put
the
get branch and then this automatically
updates
um whenever you run any archive
so it automatically stays up to date as
you change the branch
okay so the last question i think it's a
good one to close on is to think about
like what's the long
term game plan with this edition idea so
this person's like for now
in the dev version after i install it i
have to change
uh this config entry in description yep
will this still be the case indefinitely
when it's not
the dev version but it's the released
version or at some point will it default
to edition three
and someone might have to opt into
version edition two
i don't see any way to change the
default edition
from two without breaking hundreds of
cran packages
so i think that implies that the default
version will always be
two but what we will do in the tools
that we use for creating packages like
and use this
we will automatically set the config to
kind of the latest version so when you
start the kind of the idea is
that when you start a new package you
get the latest
you get the latest edition of test that
when you are working on an
old package you have to deliberately opt
into the new version if you really want
it
i think that kind of offers the best
compromise of
packages that actively develop can
easily upgrade
without touching anything that's that's
not being developed
thanks for thanks for joining us and uh
learning about
the upcoming third edition of testat
again like now is the perfect time to
give feedback on things
you like things that you hate we're
listening and we really appreciate
appreciate your feedback